juni
okay leute ist jetzt kalt geworden kann
ein bisschen mehr guck dir das mal an du
kannst es jetzt halt einfach hier so
rausnehmen und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen video
du kannst sogar aufzeigen ja ich weiß
dass auch gut du kannst mit da kann man
auch wird immer ein bisschen spielen so
dann kannst du hier auch immer ein
bisschen ruhm zum beispiel und wieder
raus so wird man ein guter filme made
against das video verkauft die den
eltern herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt gut wir
haben vor ort vorgestern und
vorvorgestern oder halt auch einfach
gesagt vor vier tagen ein paar tipps
oder gleich sechs uhr testet und das hat
sehr viel spaß gemacht deswegen gibt es
heute neun grad wir machen heute
allerdings nicht irgendwas sondern heute
geht alles um mut so leute jetzt geht's
erst mal kurz einkaufen ganz schnell mit
abstand weil ich morgen ein paar sachen
leute ich hab mir gerade eingekauft 50
euro
gut eigentlich war es nur so teuer wegen
dem waffeleisen was ich habe extra
brauchte so das war's dann auch schon
ich habe insgesamt fünf sachen
rausgesucht die wirklich also ich habe
einfach die sachen genommen die mich am
meisten angesprochen haben oder die halt
am krassesten bahn wie zb des gipfels im
waffeleisen wassermelone mit pringles
schälen oder kuchen backen und den rest
sage ich euch gleich spontan wir fahren
direkt an mit nem das war das mein handy
ist auch gut für den film maker immer
gesagt nicht auf den flugmodus wir
starten mit dem ersten das ist ein
kleiner braig festakt der richtig heiß
aussieht und ein zeichen ich erstmal
weiter bartz einfachen daumen nach oben
let's go home
bei den pacers erwartet man wartet jetzt
guck doch warum war
natürlich seien
sondern auch vorbei
diese bremer guckt ja das soll die zwar
das sieht doch gut aus schnell gemacht
ich würde sagen das machen wir als
erstes das ist eigentlich das
langweiligste und danach wird es richtig
verrückt deswegen kommt man mit ab in
die küche
wir brauchen die fahne wir brauchen eier
habe ich schon vorbereitet wir brauchen
käse habe ich auch schon vorbereitet
werden lassen mal raus einfach weil ich
das zurzeit nicht so gerne essen
deswegen ist es ja auch irgendwie
unnatürlich dann würde ich sagen der
staat direkt mal was ich allerdings euch
kurz das habe ich auch gesehen ich
wollte jetzt nicht entgehen lassen
praktisch weil wir sind jetzt quasi
schon dabei ganz kurz und zwar hat man
ja sehr auf das problem dass man das
eigelb vom eiweiß trennen muss und da
hab ich was gesehen das blende ich sehr
gern auch mal ganz 90 1
das versuchen wir mal kurz ob das
wirklich so leicht funktioniert
[Musik]
dazu wollen wir dass ein rein sagt so
und jetzt wollen wir das eigelb vom
eiweiß trennen und so in dem wir so ein
bisschen druck hier auch der flash
werkzeuge und dann das eigelb einfach
kleinkindalter so mehr den wieder was
gelernt fürs leben oder kannst du hast
schon heute gerne also wenn das video
keine 10.000 euro karten so jetzt kommt
es darauf an wir machen die fahne an und
die butter und du kannst du auch gut
kochen oder einfach nur zum gehen ganz
wichtig ich hol dir schon mal die beiden
tonspuren haus da können werde ich auch
ein bisschen butter drauf machen beier
im video auch so
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so läuft das ist schon ganz gut auf kurs
die drunter kommen
hier kommt jetzt der käse drauf ok so
leute mit anfänglichen
startschwierigkeiten hat jetzt geklappt
ich hab's ohne scheiß beim ersten mal
verpackt aber jetzt sieht es doch
perfekt aus und jetzt passt mal auf wir
haben ja keinen bock drauf aber ich
schneide jetzt trotzdem durch die ja
schon mal das ist doch was geworden nein
so er selbst soll zwar hin
wer jetzt schon das nächste gemacht
deswegen ist der käse jetzt wieder
leicht angetrocknet ich probiere das
jetzt mal es sieht auf jeden fall sehr
sehr nice aus und es riecht auch gut für
mich ist das sogar schon fast ein
bisschen zu viel also hätten auch zwei
eingeweihte wirklich ja ein recht eilig
also nimmt das war einfach nur zwei aber
zum beispiel tja schnell wenn man früher
kann funktioniert doch gehört wenn man
sich schon beim antritt muss man das
erstmal bestimmen wenn trotzdem daumen
nach oben ging es nach draußen weil
jetzt wird es ganz verrückt okay leute
zeit für einen nächsten foodtec jetzt
wird es wirklich interessant ich bin mir
unsicher ob das klappt aber ich habe da
einen videos und paar merkmale gesehen
da ich glaube das ist fake aber wir
schauen uns das erst mal ab
[Musik]
natürlich muss man sich auch erst mal
die frage stellen ob es überhaupt sinn
macht so eine wassermelone mit pringles
zu spielen weil man hat ja dann nicht
alles von der wassermelone sondern nur
so ein teil hat wobei deshalb trotzdem
ziemlich schnell geht ich habe nur
gesehen als sie diese bringen ist sie
wieder rausgezogen haben war irgendwie
hier vorne
dieses denken ja dieses silbrige teil
keine ahnung ob die das abgemacht haben
aus welchem grund auch immer weil ich
glaube das ist gar nicht mal so einfach
das hinzukriegen
trotzdem versuche ich jetzt einfach mal
dazu muss ich erstmal die chips zu hören
ich habe hier unten jetzt gerade man
auch noch reingemacht das war im video
genauso keine ahnung was ist wenn zweck
hat jetzt müssen wir die erste mal hier
oben bisschen abschneiden
[Musik]
sagen und hier kommt jetzt die dose also
so ganz glauben kann ich das noch nicht
das geht laut ascan oben jetzt muss ich
eigentlich wieder rausziehen uhr wieder
für das kam nicht mehr raus
guck das meine ich halt ich habe das für
mich auch bei anderen gesehen die hatten
auch das problem keine ahnung über das
jetzt aus kriegen sollte hat echt gut
funktioniert erst mal nicht andersrum
wie das du die andere seite reinstecken
muss war das unmöglich ist was das
vielleicht schneiden kann also warte was
machen können ich schneide das jetzt mal
hier
das erleichtert das ganze natürlich und
jetzt aber so ein spiel
man würde schön aber was dann ja auch
funktioniert kann ich mir stückchen
abnehmen aber ist ja so übelste was nur
drinnen
[Musik]
also das nicht üblich verschwendung dann
so an sich ist schon ein bisschen
verschwendung aber was wir jetzt noch
machen können
wir können jetzt ganz hier komme das
geht halt auch peinlich dass man den
rest hält auch noch erzählt naja aber es
funktioniert und darum geht es ja auch
hier daumen nach oben so leute jetzt
können wir zum nächsten jetzt wird's
richtig wild ich hab da ein sektor
gefunden
da geht es uns gefällt und pleiten
dieses tik tok hatte 22 millionen
aufrufe ich habe mir das angeschaut und
ich habe mich gefragt wieso hat es kein
ende wir schauen uns das mal zusammen
also ich bin mal gespannt ob wir dann so
eines skippers waffel haben dagegen den
sind noch zu haben
obwohl so ganz sicher bin ich mir auch
nicht dass mit dem automaten letztens
hat auch absolut keinen sinn und haben
sich trotzdem so viel angeschaut naja
ich habe auf jeden fall extra
waffeleisen hergeholt dass wir dafür
auch verschwenden kann also wenn das
jetzt so klebt oder so dann war es halt
nettes zu haben aber ist halt extra für
dieses video gekauft worden sind wollen
wir mal ich mach parallel dazu noch so
ein tick tock für meinen genial
entwickler account der hier kurz
eingeblendet ist deckt ihn auf jeden
fall deswegen fragt mich nach warum ich
so dumm räder so dann wollen wir mal die
skittles kommen einfach hier ein
auch alle die drum rum liegen einfach
reinmachen dann können wir noch ein paar
folien sauer besitz nehmen waffeleisen
zu soweit schon jetzt heißt es abwarten
ich bin echt gespannt was passiert
und ja also mit normalem
menschenverstand da kann ja nichts gutes
bei rauskommen süßigkeiten süßigkeiten
braten teil 3 ist es kann jedoch
schwierigkeiten braten von mir halbe
million klicks damals nicht nur
verbrannt er gut dass wir es draußen
noch kann ich in der zwischenzeit ein
bisschen wasser millionen anbieten wir
sind sofort fertig willst du vielleicht
wassermelone gleich gut das ist meine
erste wassermelone dieses jahr
vielleicht wird das so ein karamell
jetzt von der geruch parallel wissen
karamell den zucker
das sieht so aus wie sie sich keinen rat
mehr so schlimm
wir lassen uns noch drin also riechen
tut echt gut
aber das war es dann auch schon wieder
zu hierzu okay leute wären jetzt fünf
minuten gewartet jetzt machen wir es
auch passt auf ich bin nicht gespannt
weil ich gedacht absolut genial
also ich weiß nicht was das gebracht hat
lasst uns jetzt trotzdem abkühlen das
einzige was hier passiert ist dies
kittel sind aufgeplatzt und das ganze
zeug machen wir hier
okay leute ist jetzt kalt geworden kann
ein bisschen mehr guck dir das mal an du
kannst es jetzt halt einfach hier so
rausnehmen
hey das ist halt was hätte ich mich
gedacht das ist jetzt noch funktioniert
immer das geht nicht gut
du musst nicht stimmt das sind alles
geht so und jetzt haben wir hier eine
geniale skittles waffe sollte und zu
guter letzt ein hammer noch auf den ich
mich sehr freue ich bin wirklich
gespannt ich werde euch den hier mal
kurz ein und das wirklich so gut klappt
ich habe gedacht ich mach das im
backofen könnte vielleicht noch besser
werden
[Musik]
oder es geht halt total ratlos ich weiß
nicht wir haben noch keine mikrowelle
deswegen bleibt keine andere wahl ich
habe mir extra sonne kommen wenig
kuchenform besorgt absolut hier fühlen
wir das jetzt gleich vier das tor raus
hinzu kommen noch ein ganz bisschen
milch nicht zu viel und nicht zu wenig
und jetzt muss ich das umrühren
da kann ich mal gespannt dauert
wahrscheinlich unser eigenes und nicht
noch zusätzlich
wenn du dann gehörst hat reicht kann man
hier sieht gut aus und das kriegen wir
dann jetzt hier in die kleinen bug vorn
normalerweise die haben das ja direkt in
der taste gemacht hab mir das jetzt
jetzt kleine special will heute nach dem
motto mini kuchen kann mir das auch
gebacken wird die haben es in der
mikrowelle geballert auch müsste doch
mit backofen auch gehen oder also wenn
das hier ist nicht funktionieren gibt es
entweder an den backofen oder daran dass
ich das unbedingt um diese faktoren
führen musste so etwa 15 minuten gewacht
müsste eigentlich fertig sein riecht
zumindest so halbwegs nicht auch also
leute so sie ist jetzt aus es wäre
natürlich besser gewesen hätten wir noch
mehr gemacht messe also hätte das normal
5 rechnen müssen 25 kurios und fünfmal
die portionen milch dann wäre das jetzt
wahrscheinlich ein richtiger kuchen ist
aber egal sein aber die konsistenz sieht
auf jeden fall so aus dem video kann es
halt wirklich das ist halt wirklich
kuchen und jetzt muss es nur noch
schmecken
der geschmack ist irgendwie ein bisschen
verloren gegangen durch die milch
wahrscheinlich mac einfach nur noch
möglichen schokokuchen kommen auf jeden
fall richtig fest geworden
hast du alle die sich jetzt fragen wie
lange habe ich das im backofen drinnen
gehabt also circa 15 minuten 180 grad
und dann man kann aber auch sehen wann
es fertig ist also das war jetzt deutsch
perfekt ist auch ganz locker gewesen
foto re match 5 hinter uns das spaß
so herrscht in europa wir sehen uns
übermorgen wieder gibt es neuen part von
mal was anderes bestimmt dank fürs
zuschauen danke mir als film und
instagram angeklickt hat sich bald auch
alex wilks geändert haut rein
hallo leute was geht heute herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen live act ich
zeige euch heute wie hier skittles
waffel macht dafür kauft ihr euch extra
ein waffeleisen was ihr nur einmal
benutzen könnt dann skittles einmal ganz
normal und ballert die einfach hier
drauf auf alle die drum herum liegen
einfach reinmachen dann können wir noch
ein paar von den saudis nehmen stroman
waffeleisen zu ungefähr fünf minuten
warten und
dafür ein like